(people speaking in foreign language)
(building collapsing)
(pensive music)
(water whooshing)
(booming sounds)
(man speaking in foreign language)
- [Brett] Kharkiv has
been a major objective
for the Russians pretty
much from the beginning
of this conflict.
It has seen some of the
fiercest fighting so far
in this war.
As the hours and days go by,
we're seeing more and more
targeting of civilian sites,
and we're seeing a lot
more civilian deaths
and casualties there.
(pensive music)
(man speaking in foreign language)
(men speaking in foreign language)
(material rustling)
(alarm ringing)
(people talking indistinctly)
(water rushing)
(pensive music)
(Davide speaking in foreign language)
(people speaking in foreign language)
(pensive music)
(Volodymyr speaking in foreign language)
- [Brett] The Kremlin spokesman signaled
that Russia is indeed ready
for a second round of talks.
It's unclear at this point
whether those are taking place
and if something of substance
would really result anyway.